so you're talking about something  religious reconciliation is a very  different thing then drivers for  extremism those are two different  animals that we're talking about over  here so if you're asking have I  witnessed communities our culture's out  there that are more amenable to  religious comfortable discussions about  religion and forgiveness that's not what  I do so I can't I you know what I mean I  haven't looked at it things from that  perspective or that angle so I can't  tell you gosh it's so much more that way  in western Africa than it is in southern  Asia I can't I cannot because that's not  the way in which I've looked at things